how did your distribution deal oh they
came to us they came to us we had a very
successful screening at the frame line
festival in san francisco we filled the
castro theater there were over a
thousand people it was a thrilling
experience they got every joke they
cried they laughed they stood up they
cheered it was extraordinary I'm his
extraordinary and I think someone from
breaking glass was at that screening and
they approached us they came to us and
they wanted the film and they pursued us
rather aggressively what were certain
things that you made sure we're in your
distribution deal that you would advise
other filmmakers look out for certainly
getting the best percentages that you
can that's all matter of negotiation and
also making sure that the reports are
part of the deal that they the
distributing company has to report the
specifics of what's happened of monies
earned and in what way and in what time
when you rat was at the frontline
festival yeah was there a QA frame line
Oh frame loss I think I may have said
from what's the frame line festival was
their QA yes there was yeah what were
some of the questions that the only
assess they were very interested in the
cast I had a huge cast they're all
trained actors I'm a trained actor I'm
not very good but I do know how to act I
made myself do that because when you're
making a movie you you need to be on the
playing field with your actors because
it is it's like a sport they're running
plays and unless you know how to run
those plays it's very difficult for
actors working with directors who don't
know really what the skill is they were
very interested in where I found the
actors they were
fascinated to hear the chaser was a
heterosexual very womanly woman who was
playing the transgender so they asked
sort of very general interest questions
little shy they're a little shy when
they ask those questions
you